I've got a great documentary
recommendation for you today I saw this
a couple of months ago topspin okay this
is a 2014 full-length documentary it is
about table tennis may be known to you
colloquially as ping pong but I learned
from the documentary that the proper
name for the sport is table tennis and
it follows a number of table tennis
athletes on their road to the 2012
summer olympics it's a three young
American table tennis players and it is
absolutely fascinating I was never
hugely into table tennis I i I'm
comfortable calling a table tennis now
used to always say ping pong but I'll
call a table tennis now my dad has a
table tennis uh table I guess is what
it's called in his basement and
sometimes I'll play I enjoy it but I was
never really into the sport although i
did find those videos interesting where
the players are like 10 feet back
seemingly from the table smacking the
ball in watching this documentary I
learned number one a lot more about
sport and the sport is fascinating but
more interestingly number too many of
the best table tennis players start
really really young but it's not casual
right you see the training you see them
getting pulled out of school to spend
hours practicing and training intensely
with coaches you see the travel you see
all of the drama that goes on which
probably exists with most sports no
matter what what sport it is and the
documentary is endlessly fascinating i
have you heard of this one pat i have
and i'm really not too big into table
tennis myself ya know i i'm not hugely
into it either but just seeing this
world is fascinating I'm not hugely into
curling for example but I bet if there
was a curling documentary and there
probably is one there's a good chance
that I'd be interested in the
documentaries I'm just interested in
seeing there's an entire world there I
watched a documentary recently this is
my documentary recommendation for top
spin but i'll mention recently I watched
a documentary about Magic the Gathering
the card game it's like a role playing
card game that will producer Louis was
hugely into I could not care less about
magic the gathering I don't know if it's
a major an orc or you've tapped man I
don't know anything about it
but just seeing how into it these people
are in the tournament etcetera it's
absolutely fascinating it makes sense to
cos is a lot of people who like watching
like sports documentaries because it's a
it's a nice story about like someone
starting from nothing and gradually
getting better yeah but they're they're
not interested in sports themselves yep
no doubt about it and that applies to
the the 30 for 30 series yet which is
it's in all ways in some way related to
sports although sometimes less directly
like the two escobars is one where it
talks about the Colombian soccer team
but really it's about pop Pablo Escobar
and the control that the major cocaine
dealer had over so many areas of life
including a soccer and those are really
really good and appeal to a lot of
people who are not hugely into sports
individually so to restate the
documentary is top spin it's on netflix
and of course you can check out this and
all of my recommendations at david
pakman.com slash recommendations we've
got a hell of a show for you today and
i'm glad you're with us